you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video
starting out as a curious experiment of
sorts video games have come a long way
over the past half-century today we have
all sorts of games ranging from detailed
storylines
to multi player chaos the graphics of
our games today aren't far off the CGI
films from a decade ago
and moreover the gaming industry brought
in twenty three billion dollars of
revenue last year but where did it all
come from and what are the very origins
of what we call video games today in
this video we'll travel back in time a
little bit and find out when most people
think of the origin of video games their
mind wanders to the classic arcade game
pong but pong and the corresponding
arcade era was actually the end stage of
pioneering video games and not the
beginning to find the first piece of
video game code ever written we have to
start three years after World War two in
1948 Alan Turing who was actually the
father of AI and David Champ a noun
wrote a theoretical chess simulation
called Turo champ this was the first
game code ever written unfortunately it
would never run on a computer as the
code was too complicated to actually run
on machines over the time the early
1950s saw the first video games to run
on a machine of course the computers
back then were large glorified
calculators that took up an entire room
but there was an issue though for a
second put yourself in the shoes of an
engineer in 1950 if you wanted to
demonstrate a computer's usefulness to
someone who didn't even know what a
computer was how would you do it in an
interesting and engaging way the answer
with tech demos of course created in
1950 virtually the brain was one of the
first of such demo games it was
basically noughts and crosses which is
light bulbs as a display in 1952 al
Xander Douglas created another noughts
and crosses game but took it a step
further
he used a video display instead of light
bulbs although this was a step forward
the game featured new interactive moving
graphics so some historians do not view
this as the first two video game
possibly the first real video game and
the first created simply for
entertainment purposes was tennis for
two in 1958
it featured moving graphics on an
oscilloscope American physicist William
Higinbotham
designed the game to be shown at a
public exhibition here's how we
discovered how to make the game while
reading the instruction manual for a
Donner model 30 computer which was an
analogue computer used by the US
government
William learned that the computer could
calculate basic missile trajectories or
a bouncing ball with wind resistance he
decided to use these abilities to form
the foundation of a game this was
actually the very first interactive
computer game the game was a smash hit
during the three-day exhibition with
players lining up to see the game high
school students were especially
enthralled although this was an iconic
moment in videogame history it was yet
to break out as a media forum as the
years passed there were still no such
thing as a video game industry almost
all games had been developed on a single
machine for a specific purpose a
software game that could run on multiple
machines was not yet realized this all
changed in 1961 when MIT acquired the
dec pdp-11 Peter which used a vector
display system although it had no CPU
the transistors still managed to 5
megahertz processing speed which is
about 500 times slower than the clock
speed in a modern smartphone actually
very powerful for 1961 because of the
computers small size and speed students
and employees of MIT loved writing
non-academic programs whenever it wasn't
being used
in 1962 three MIT employees Martin
grades Steve Russell and Wayne
Whittington created the game space war
on the PDP one the two-player game
involved a dog fire between two
spaceships set against the backdrop of
the star field interestingly one of the
aims of the game's design was to use up
all of the computer's resources and
utilize every part of the machine so in
essence what you're looking at is the
maximum performance of 1961 technology I
think it was actually pretty impressive
for what they had space war was copied
to other mini computers in other
American universities making it the
first video game to be available outside
a single Research Institute despite this
the game wasn't widespread as the PDP
one cost $120,000 or almost a million
dollars in today's currency and only 55
were ever sold as a side point if he
think space war looks familiar the game
actually inspired asteroids by Atari in
1979 but more an Atari later on in the
video
following the spread of space war
further computer games were developed by
programmers at other universities the
1970s saw an uptick in the number of
video games being created but there were
still known commercial games yet alone a
smash hit title to start a gaming
revolution until 1972 that is here's how
it happened inspired by the MIT games
space war two guys Nolan Bushnell and
Ted Dabney decided to create a
coin-operated version of the game in
1971 it was called computer space and
went on to be the first arcade video
game as well as the first commercially
available video game it was a moderate
success and was profitable but the pair
thought that they could do better they
immediately started work on another game
and decided to found their own company
called
Atari incorporated initially this next
game was to be a driving game but Ataris
first employee Allan Alcorn was given
the project of making a simple ping pong
game as training while Ellen was working
on the training project Bushnell saw the
progress and already thought that the
game was pretty fun so much so that
Atari should just actually release it
this training project ping pong
became the first video game smash hit
that will go down forever in history its
name became pong pong was unleashed in
1972 and it was immensely successful
selling over eight thousand cabinet
arcades across America
the secret to pong success was the use
of a low-cost TV monitor as an example a
vector monitor in those days cost
$15,000 and whereas you could use a TV
set 400 and that was kind of one of the
metaphors and allowed it to be every
words to infuse specialized computer
centers
it was a great social experience that
was going on the number of people that
have told me in last 25 years that they
met their husband or wife playing pong
it's been in the hundreds 1972 also saw
the release of the Magnavox Odyssey the
first home video game console seconds to
create a closed-circuit electronic
playground Odyssey is tips
analogic now video games had come out of
arcades and straight into the home the
Odyssey was the first video gaming
device to be in a television commercial
it sold for about five hundred seventy
dollars in today's currency and shipped
with several games even though the
Odyssey was extremely primitive it was
still a brand new medium of
entertainment for the household and
because of this it was immensely
successful selling over 100,000 units in
1972 alone pong and the Odyssey had
kicked off a new era in video gaming
from this time numerous competitors
began to pop up to create a new video
game industry over the years the
computing power and graphics would
improve and despite the video game crash
of 1983 the industry came rebounding
with knee strength in the 1990s
storyline to become a bigger part of the
gaming experience and soon vast
imaginative world became a possibility
the 2000s saw photorealistic graphics
become feasible and now in the 2010s
we're on the verge of the next
revolutionary stage in gaming virtual
reality so as I said at the beginning of
this video and as you can now see we've
come a long way
alright guys that's the end of the video
so thanks for watching the whole way
through if you enjoyed this video please
give a thumbs up if you liked it share
it with someone who would be interested
and leave a comment stating the first
video game that you ever play thanks for
watching guys this has been - go go
you've been watching cold fusion and
I'll catch you again soon for the next
video
cheers guys enjoy yourself and have a
good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
you
you